[Musica]
questi che ne sanno di fila in questura
delle mille facce della mia cultura e la
melanina ciò che li cattura io non ho
dei dubbi sulla mia natura quando il rap
è in italiano e anche se parto resto in
italiano
la prima volta che ho detto ti amo c
giuro l'ho fatto in italiano e 83 ad hoc
che i cartoni sul 6 con cristina d'avena
rassina rap che raggio con me quando
tutta sta gente non mi conosceva ancora
razzisti quelli della lega
ogni 2 giugno su quella bandiera quando
una foto i parenti nigeria mangiando una
fetta di pizza per tele sono a free
tagliati queste parole vengono dalla
seconda strofa della mia canzone afro
italiana in questa canzone ho provato a
raccontare una storia una delle tante
storie legate ai ragazzi afro
discendenti che ci sono qua in questo
paese qua la scrittrice e nigeriana si
domanda cosa parla del problema legato
alla singola storia
no perché ammettiamolo in questo paese
qua
spesso si parla di noi ragazzi di
seconda generazione
però se il problema della singola storia
nel senso che tutte le tutto l'universo
delle esperienze che possono condividere
delle persone facente parte una comunità
sono legate a un semplice cresce con la
mia storia è quella di un ragazzo di
provincia vengono da un paesino ricordo
che indurrà intorno ai 15 anni ho
scoperto il rap italiano col mio amico
mario ascoltavamo rap italiano è solo
figlio di florence di sangue due ragazzi
ventenni che sono venuti in italia due
ragazzi che sono venuti in italia da
ventenni hanno deciso di crescere la
propria famiglia in questo paese hanno
lavorato nelle aziende nelle fabbriche
del bresciano e poi hanno aperto la
propria attività
ci sono miei amici italiani come me ma
se nati di letteratura di dante
boccaccio che hanno frequentato il liceo
sa chi come me che non sa scegliere se
preferisce mangiare il soul of rights
uno dei piatti tipici nigeriani oppure
della sagne no questo fa parte anche
questo di una storia no ho la mia amica
zara kahn che l'attivista scrivi che ha
un attivista scrittrice che è cresciuta
sino a napoli che è cresciuta in
campagna e quando parla si esprima con
un accento campano che io trovo
fantastico ed è una ragazza flow
discendente c'è un uomo che vive dalle
parti di padova e parla con le remote e
ha creato una rubrica intitolata se non
sai chiedi dove raccontare le persone la
propria storia ed è riuscito a
trasformare la propria passione per la
musica propiziano un lavoro che
condivide con migliaia di persone
vedete tutte queste qua sono storie
diverse però se ci pensiamo
quando uno pensa stranieri in italia la
prima immagine che gli viene in mente è
quella di una bella barca piano di di
stranieri che stanno venendo in questo
in questo paese qua e sfatiamo il mito
forse non ci crederete ma per quando si
parli spesso degli sbarchi così dicono
che statisticamente meno di un per cento
degli stranieri che vengono qua in
italia vengono qua con gli sbarchi
al di là delle statistiche la media dei
casi tutti i miei amici con il quale
sono cresciuto nel mio quartiere
abbiamo storia di uno dei nostri
genitori che sono venuti qua hanno preso
il visto da un paese dell'africa
esistenti trasferiti qua non c'è nulla
di male essere venuti qua in italia con
un barcone per ben due volte in italia
con un barcone si è fatta due volte la
tratta cosa posso dire però ci sono le
storie dei ragazzi del mio quartiere per
esempio io vengo da un quartiere che si
chiama i cinque continenti in questo
quartiere eravamo quasi tutti al 99 per
cento
figli di stranieri compagni i miei amici
del quartiere sono cresciuti cioè che è
diventato avvocato che è diventato
dottore che ha giocato a calcio che ha
aperto un azienda che ha aperto una
azienda un'attività no tante tante
storie diverse però ammettiamolo cioè in
media hanno un potere incredibile perché
i miei 32 anni di vita in italia nella
metà dei casi ogni volta che ha acceso
la televisione ho sentito sempre urlare
questi termini qua tipo emergenza
immigrazione sbarchi extracomunitario o
questi termini qua hanno il loro potere
sono potenti entrano nella mente delle
persone
faccio un esempio persino io c'è anche
posso essere vittima di questa cosa qua
io mi ricordo che quando hai ragione
quando ero piccolo quando ero piccolo
se una persona mi diceva io sono
albanese che prendevo male mi spaventa è
che quando io avevo il timore delle
persone provenienti dall'albania
non conoscevo una singola persona
albanese nessun albanese faceva parte
della mia vita
però avevo sentito parlare di questo
popolo per sentito dire se visto un
sacco di articoli di giornale avevo
visto un sacco di servizi alla
televisione
avevo sentito i miei amici bresciani
dire certe cose su di loro e quindi sono
rimasto influenzato da questo
pregiudizio qua che ha superato
conoscendo delle persone albanese
pensate alla potenza dei media in media
all 1
hanno un potere possono influenzare la
tua percezione di te stesso
mi ricordo che quando andavo a scuola
quando una persona diceva biondo con gli
occhi azzurri era sinonimo di fidenza
era bellissimo sa io mi ricordo che
persino io ho avuto una fase della vita
in cui sognato di avere una bella donna
bionda con gli occhi azzurri però perché
sognavo di avere una bella
donna bionda con gli occhi azzurri
perché la metà dei casi quando guardavo
un film guardava la televisione il
protagonista alla persona più importante
del film e rabbia bella bionda con gli
occhi azzurri
non a caso se ci pensate gran parte
delle rappresentazioni di cristo nel
cristianesimo non raffigurano biondo con
gli occhi azzurri perché quello la
bellezza il modello di bellezza al quale
ambire e classici pensate questa è una
cosa dovuto a quello che si è detto alle
storie che si è raccontato e di media
attraverso la rappresentazione possono
anche aiutare vi faccio un esempio sono
certo che tutti voi avete quell'amico
razzista che è razzista però michael
jordan e un grande razzista però ma il
consenso l'hai visto come balla o oppure
razzista ma i film di will smith sono i
migliori perché i film giurisdizione
migliori perché michael jackson lo
ammira più di quanto ami gravi ne ho
altri ragazzi nati o cresciuti qui
perché di queste persone qua a una
storia conosce sa qualcosa a letto
articoli di giornale che vanno al di là
dei al di là di informazioni negative
invece si può dire che per quanto
riguarda ne affronti discendente in
questo paese ce la giochiamo da una
parte senza tutto l'universo dei cliché
spaccio droga sbarchi e poi abbiamo
balotelli no faccio l'esempio balotelli
perché mi sento preso mi sento toccato
personalmente io mi ricordo intorno al
2012 quando balotelli ha fatto quei due
gol alla germania nel 2012 quanto era
bello essere nero a brescia ricordo che
io tutti i miei amici del quartiere
andavano in giro con questa questa qua e
quando eravamo in giro i vecchi bersani
ci salutavano era bello perché lui stava
dando una rappresentazione positiva poi
cosa è successo
e passato del tempo e magari balotelli
ha smesso di fare qua e quindi a quel
punto quei vecchi per i sani siamo
tornati ad essere negarne no
ormai siamo nel 2021 e anche in questo
paese ci sono tanti altri esempi di
ragazzi afro discendenti che fanno cose
interessanti ammirevoli
al di là di balotelli però purtroppo
forse si può dire che siano un po troppo
pigri per scoprirli no ad esempio sono
la mia amica rai 3 in a
angela e ai veleni che sono delle
ragazze che aiutano le persone con i
capelli ricci a prendersi cura dei
propri capelli e ad ammirare i propri
capelli nella loro naturalezza
sono amico tim la sla di daniel mann e
di aiom idee che sono delle atlete pluri
per che sono delle atlete pluripremiate
che attraverso la propria piattaforma
cercando di parlare e di comunicare di
raccontare anche loro nei loro le
proprie storie
per esempio daniel madame parla spesso
di come è importante cambiare la legge
di cittadinanza come importante che le
persone come me
nate e vissute in questo paese non
debbano soffrire non debbano aspettare
il 20 e passa anni per poter sentirsi
cittadini
e sapete avete presente tik tok no
sempre parlando di storia in questo
momento il tic toc air italiano più
conosciuto in assoluto si chiama cavi lo
conoscono in tutto il mondo dal brasile
all america all'africa
era un ragazzo che abita in piemonte ha
superato pure gianluca vacchi con i tic
tornò e devo ammettere che io sono
dell'ottantanove anch'io mi sento un po
vecchio in questo universo qua
anch'io sto scoprendo un buffissimo in
realtà grazie a questa tecnologia qua
per esempio un'altra tik tok era
conosciutissima e aida una ragazza che
porta il velo abita dalle parti di
romano vicino avrei sa e guardando i
suoi tic toc anch'io ho scoperto una
nuova realtà un nuovo mondo che non
conoscevo ma poi c'è per esempio isabeau
che è un po comico però sapete che per
essere comici bisogna essere proprio
attenti essere in grado di fare una
attenta critica sociale quindi saba
attraverso il suo canale tik tok riesce
a comunicare insegnare alle persone
quello che succede nelle case di noi
italiani
un po li invidio questi ragazzi della
generazione tik tok perché quando io
andavo a scuola purtroppo devo
confessarvi
che tutti i miei compagni di classe al
99 per cento non potevano avere non
potevano avere lontanamente l'idea di
quello che accada accadesse nella mia
casa è invece attraverso questa
tecnologia ci stiamo avvicinando a
quella democrazia digitale che è
importante raggiungere cambiare le
storie e portarne di nuovo e per portare
di nuovo
cos'è nella nel mondo cosa che ha sempre
portato nuove storia e lepri no la
cultura è anche da questo punto di vista
il mondo degli altri italiani a ha dato
un grandissimo contributo a questo paese
c'è una ragazza di origini nigeriane
scrive c'è speranza
se la mia amica a loretta grace tutte
persone che si sono impegnate per
raccontare un po la storia della propria
gente e finalmente si stanno essendo dei
segnali positivi
quest'anno riuscita la serie di netflix
0 con questa seria qua io quando ho
visto quando l'ho vista ho avuto dei
momenti in cui ero commosso avevo di
privi di incredibile questa serie
ispirata al libro di antonio di che le
di stefano e perché ero commosso vederla
raga era la prima volta in 32 anni di
vita che vedevo dei personaggi in
televisioni inseguo quale potrebbe
essere mio amico questa storia sarebbe
potuto accadere nel quartiere dove sono
cresciuto e il vero un po amareggiato
anche da un altro punto di vista dovete
sapere che io oltre a fare musica
faccio faccio l'attore sono iscritto in
un'agenzia di un'agenzia per fare cassa
in d'attore e ogni settimana devo fare
dei casting per del film al 99 per cento
più delle parti che mi propongono sono
sempre di una persona che uno
spacciatore o di una persona che non
parla l'italiano potrebbe immaginare la
frustrazione
ho passato tutta la mia vita imparare a
parlare bene l'italiano e poi mi ha
richiesto di recitare sono ruoli in cui
non lo devo parlare bene io come ho
detto ci sono dei segnali positivi però
credo che le cose cambieranno veramente
quando anche noi a fluidi scendente
anche taffo discendenti saremo inclusi
proprio nella realizzazione delle cose
vi faccio un esempio l'anno scorso è
uscito questo film nel quale recita
sofia loren che apprezzo lo sforzo è una
cosa carina
però in questo film quasi a lei c'è il
protagonista c'è l'altro protagonista
del film un ragazzo di 12 anni e
dominate che cosa fa sto ragazzino non
va a scuola e spazza
raga ho 32 anni e mai nella mia vita ho
mai conosciuto un ragazzino di 12 anni
che non va a scuola e spazza e al di là
di quello io penso al produttore regista
di questo film magari è stato pigro a
scegliere di raccontare solo questa
storia qua perché se ci pensate
sarebbe stato sufficiente approfondire
andare oltre a quel cresce perché ci
sono altre storie positive io non mi
dimenticherò un paio di anni fa sono
andato al alla presentazione dell'album
diga è rimasto commosso perché ho visto
tutti i suoi fan che caduta che
cantavano le sue canzoni in arabo e
alcuni ragazzi sapevano i dread come lui
per essere come lui non si facevano da
blake face come fanno spesso in
televisione il suo wow
questa è l'italia di cui faccio parte
questo è il futuro
questo è il mio mondo e in quel momento
ho realizzato che il mio compito
la mia missione come artista è quella di
utilizzare la mia piattaforma per
raccontare delle storie far conoscere
delle storie e sono certo che vuole da
casa vi domanderete ma se io non sono
afrodiscendenti cosa posso fare per
aiutare cosa posso fare per migliorare
le cose
credo che compito di tutti noi non solo
mio
anche di voi da casa sia quello di
approfondire e andare oltre alla
superficie di cercare di andare nel
profondo di questa storia qua da quello
che io provo a fare con i mie canzoni
però credo che anch'io abbia molto
ancora da imparare
sono moltissimo da imparare
vi lascio con questa strofa della mia
canzone io utilizzo la mia musica al mio
medium per raccontare le storie e la
musica principalmente ho sudato azzurro
lavoravo quando tu hai fumato il primo
spino tutti fingi malandrino da quella
vita you fuggivo se arriva la non
parlare
una giungla qui c'è un'altra legge bene
c'è male ma bene o male ogni uomo fa
quello che serve
io corro mai negata fuggo dalla ap zone
blu come mandela sono made in ingegneria
combatto offrirà la finn john boyega e
meno chance se sei cresciuto da certe
parti conta dove va in onda dove parte
il brutto anatroccolo ora un'asta some
un party comico